let's jump into that first story we got
this one from the daily caller
paul
young men of both political parties
think feminism does more harm than good
sounds it sounds like toxic masculinity
to me tim you're right except republican
women of all ages also really don't like
it interesting well but hold on what is
a republican woman
well i suppose
if we're talking about identities a
republican woman is a republican adult
human female
sounds like a democrat could be
something totally different well because
now that i mean look look
obviously we have wonderful progress in
this era where a word can mean whatever
you want it to mean instead of what it
actually means and so maybe it's the
case unfortunately that there's a
negative side effect here where
men are just saying that they're women
disguising themselves as women and then
telling these pollsters feminism is bad
to make us think women oppose it what if
these are democrat what if these are
republican men who don't realize because
they identify as democrats that they're
not really democrats
i actually not really men i actually
think that's an argument they would
entertain they're like well if a
democrat means he hates feminism he's
actually a conservative there you go
yeah so he's just wrongly identifying my
biggest problem with it is that the
definition of feminism has changed over
the years there's actually four to five
waves of feminism my mother was raised
she raised me kind of as like a second
wave feminist where it was about
equality of opportunity for every person
didn't really matter what your gender
was and that was basically it it was
never like talking down to men it never
was about making men because i used to
ask you like as a question as a kid does
that mean men aren't bad does it mean
women are better and she said no no
there's about quality of opportunity for
these people first wave feminism was the
we should get to vote right
we should have and second wave feminism
was that no more firm open palm slaps on
the behind from men in the workplace
kind of stuff like essentially like
equality in the workplace you know you
that that
i don't know 1950s era smoking you know
guys smoking like come here
that stuff's out the sexual revolution i
think birth control credit cards and
bank accounts things like that in the
70s 60s that's fascinating though tell
me about that well it used to be that
women used to have a harder time with
that kind of thing um you know being
able to get mortgages and bank accounts
and things so you know when like the
equal rights act and everything was able
to help us with that well so but do you
know why that was was it was it like men
and banks were like babe you think i'm
giving you a loan never going to happen
yeah get out of here i i think that was
the 20s though by the way in the 70s
they were hippies right yeah i i think
that it was you know just previously not
illegal to discriminate against somebody
because of their sex and so you know
maybe for whatever reason banks just
said you know well maybe as a woman
you're gonna have a baby and not pay
your loan back or whatever it was for
whatever reason they just didn't tend to
extend credit to women i think you know
what it probably was the woman would go
in and get a credit card and they would
say
and is your husband okay with this and
when they were like my husband doesn't
matter they'd say well he pays the bills
doesn't he so you know before women were
as prominent in the workplace or in
higher positions they probably just said
you you have lower credit just
inherently by not doing these jobs sure
could be looking up well this is the
kind of feminism that most people are
like yeah that's cool you know like you
shouldn't discriminate on these ba like
it should be your job it should be your
actual credit
not
you know you got boobs can't have a
credit card that seems like arbitrary
but these payments that's from 1963
signed by kennedy i haven't looked too
deeply into how it's uh read but equal
payback it's a labor law prohibits
gender-based wage discrimination i feel
like that was made redundant by the 1964
civil rights act could have been maybe a
precursor to that yeah
so now feminism you know probably the
reason young men don't like it is that
modern feminism is is what a catch-all
term for basically all sorts of weird
bigotry discrimination
rage
even violence i think even from the
gekko though when there were arguments
to be made that women were being treated
unfairly in certain respects the
feminist movement was still mostly
pushing for this so to speak privileges
men had rather than the responsibilities
even at that time so for example
women couldn't vote they also couldn't
be drafted part of why many women didn't
want the right to vote at that time is
because they thought it was going to
come along with a duty to be drafted
which feminists at that time did not
argue for while they were arguing for
the vote
so you're saying women should be drafted
well no my point is that i think part of
the issue is even from the beginning
when we're discussing legitimate issues
feminists were more or less they were
saying men and women are equal and
should be treated equally in every
respect but then they would conveniently
ignore the responsibilities men had
which women didn't and not pursue
equality there
yeah with rights come responsibilities
um i looked it up to also just to
clarify it was 1974 the equal credit
opportunity act to prohibit credit
discrimination on gender wow well what's
your what's your view you're the the
clinical psychologist here i'm curious
what your thoughts are on modern
feminism
yeah i mean that's a
such a loaded issue right um i mean i
think tim that probably i kind of go
with you and in the sense that i'm
obviously for equal rights for everybody
um but i think a lot of women actually
kind of want the right to be more
traditional the right to be able to
be respected as a woman to be able to
recognize that homemaking and
housewifery and raising babies that
those things actually really matter and
you know girls getting kind of pushed
into this stuff
under the guise of girl power is
sometimes not quite so empowering also
as a boy mom myself meaning i'm a mom to
a son
i think also some of this you know girl
power stuff has actually gone a little
bit too far to the point where it's
hurting boys which is actually also
hurting girls you know to the point
where girls don't want to date weak men
but that's unfortunately what some of
this like over the top girl power stuff
seems to be doing you say it hurts boys
like what's an example of that that
you've seen
well i mean so if if we
are
praising and helping girls to the point
where for example girls are outpacing
boys when it comes to college graduation
or graduate school girls are actually
also paid more than boys now on average
upon graduation from college so i mean
these are just
a few examples but obviously also boy's
suicide rate is is much higher
and other types of problems
and so when we're you know just still
for whatever reason still focusing on
you know more federal dollars to help
girls in school when in fact it's boys
who have a literacy crisis
so anyway all of the focus on girls i
think is kind of um a little bit
superfluous at this point well this
sounds like really good news for young
chads right if the average man is making
less money than the women they're
basically out of the out of the dating
pool and then the very small proportion
of chad young millennium you know gen z
men who are making all the money get all
the women you and you see the problem
well you see this all the time whenever
there's some twitter thread that goes
viral about someone who's using tinder
and she finds a guy that she likes and
she swipes on him and then finds out
he's been talking to 20 other girls it's
like well that's because you swiped on
like 99 guys swiped on that one guy and
it was the same thing for all other
girls so he just had a bunch of options
that's what ends up happening when
the monogamous social standards break
down but also i agree with what you're
saying i think it's very interesting
because you'll have these nebulous
campaigns about how girls are called
bossy more often which isn't really
something we can test for have
statistics on and yet we ignore the fact
that boys are put on
that's an argument yeah but it's there
was a whole campaign ban bossy right and
we were told that we should all kind of
like hang our heads in shame because
when girls are assertive they're told
they're bossy and no one at the same
time will talk about the fact that
boys are more likely to be prescribed
adhd medicine in school they are
literally chemically altered because our
public educational system is failing
them and no one seems to consider it an
issue they also we're also chemically
altering young girls with birth control
yes
agree and i well i think that's a
problem as well hormonal birth control
causes problems that no one's willing to
acknowledge i've never experienced a
work environment where people have
complained about a female who was bossy
like i've never i've heard the argument
but i've never been in an environment
where i'm like at lunch and someone's
like man that janet's so bossy i've just
never haven't i've heard people be like
my boss is a dick and i'd be like who's
your boss it's john i'm like oh mm-hmm
or like who's janet or it's jenner yeah
i don't like my boss how about that too
yeah i don't know it's just most people
don't like their bosses
you know i just it's a it's a weird
thing that's like i wonder if that is in
itself sexism these assumptions
yeah you know the assumption of
victimhood the assumption
i'll tell you something else man
i was talking to this guy who produces
documentaries and we were talking about
this issue and he was like he told me he
was like my experience was that whenever
we would have pitch meetings the women
in the meeting room would be giving us
stupid ideas and then everyone will be
getting really frustrated annoyed with
these really dumb ideas and then she
would complain that no one takes her
opinion seriously because she's a woman
and we try to explain to her notes
because your ideas are dumb but she took
it to the female place instead of the
bed at her job place and you know it was
because she was brought into the room
because she was a woman because they
needed diversity it's true that can
happen and then also because women can
sometimes be more sensitive to criticism
right and and if you do criticize that
woman's ideas in the boardroom then you
know you can get this big reaction of
like you know well you know you're
you're undermining me because i'm a
woman or you're not taking me seriously
because i'm a woman and you know what
they're doing unfortunately then is
depriving themselves of the chance to
have real honest feedback and
collaboration and even to you know
engage and spar and develop and improve
because they're bringing it all you know
to being a woman and so then nobody does
comment nobody wants to say anything
unless it's going to be really you know
nice and nice and then they wonder why
nobody ultimately goes forward with
those ideas
yep
i think when you have when you have uh
what's the quota filled roles
you're going to see a lot more of this
where people who are minorities or women
are going to feel like there's racism i
mean maybe that's maybe that's the goal
maybe maybe many of these activists want
to create this by putting people who are
unskilled in positions they're not
qualified for so that they feel
inadequate constantly and then the
person can come in and say oh that
feeling racism well we have to
understand this is a very very serious
problem because whenever we talk about
the idea of like marginalized
communities whether you're talking about
you know the alphabet people or you're
you're talking about people who are you
know minorities because of their ethnic
group in this country
the most serious problem i think is the
breakdown of the relationship between
men and women because that is the most
fundamentally important social
relationship that exists men are
supposed to open pickle jars
well but no i mean we people will talk
about like sexism homophobia etc and i
think with sexism unfortunately whenever
there are issues that are addressed with
the relationship between the sexes it's
always in one direction the conversation
can only ever be
women are being treated unfairly and men
are bad and what's interesting about
that is there's actually kind of a
kernel of traditionalism and natural law
in that because people recognize that it
is the role of men to protect women and
to care for women and to provide for
them and so it's sort of bizarre because
we have this concoction where we're told
that men and women are exactly equal but
also men still have to fulfill this
traditional role of being the one who
cares for her and protects her and who's
tough and has a thick skin like remember
that amber heard taper she's like tell
him johnny tell him that you know that
you were abused you know and and she's
just like you know see who believes you
exactly yeah yeah
and then nobody talks about toxic
femininity of course you know but but
toxic masculinity all the time is this
big thing so i think you're absolutely
right it's it's just it's so much more
normalized and comfortable for people
whether it's at school or work or
personal lives or whatever to just trash
talk men yeah well what is let's let's
can i i just want to make a point about
toxic masculinity this is a term which
they always fiend confusion over
whenever anyone points out that it's
offensive it is clearly an intentionally
provocative phrase if you wanted to get
authentically masculine men on board
with your project you would not label
their bad behavior as a form of
masculinity you would say something like
well actually these men are behaving in
an effeminate way when they treat women
poorly because they're not being men who
are protectors instead they label it
masculinity and go well why why would
you be against us calling it toxic
masculine it's like because you're
attacking men in general and then
claiming you're only attacking a small
subsection thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there